is the role that got away from you when
you were going to be cast as Superman I
think it's when JJ Abrams was in charge
of the Superman franchise someone had
approached you about being Superman and
then suddenly it was taken away from you
is that correct everyone in town was
reading for Superman like again we're
testing I think maybe six or seven guys
in 2002 three who are the guys who was
being tested do you remember I remember
Paul Walker oh it was before me they
were like you know the usual suspects so
you know of course it's a life-changing
amazing opportunity but you had to I had
to reconcile with okay
say you do get the job to be the man of
steel it's going to be chipped on your
gravestone are you okay with that I mean
right forevermore be known as the man
stale
um there was sort of a Faustian bargain
that went in to feeling yeah and I think
inherently I didn't want to be known for
only one thing because I prided myself
on diversity my whole professional life
and I I'd like I mean I'm not a
one-trick pony but how hurt were you
that you didn't get it were you at the
time very very bummed out I felt
disappointed that there was an amazing
opportunity and it didn't come to
fruition it had to do a lot with some
really Shenanigans and Studio politics
and and and probably probably inherently
in my screen test I think that's why you
test you could kind of see I wasn't I
was only there like 98 instead so maybe
you were there 98 because the two
percent of you was going I don't think
that's good for my career and you
weren't fully committed to that yeah
Superman role exactly